Herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 35. Ausgabe, die wie auch schon die letzte hier in Holland am Standort der ESA am Estec stattfindet. Und heute geht's mal um ein Thema, was sich mal wieder so zwischen den Zeilen befindet, hier im gesamten Raumfahrtprogramm. Nichtsdestotrotz, aber auch eng damit verzahnt ist. Genauer geht es um den Technologietransfer, das Technologietransferprogramm der ESA. Und um darüber Auskunft zu geben, begrüße ich Frank, Frank Salzgeber. Hallo. Ja, Technologietransfer. Naja, also dass das hier alles eine Menge mit Technologie zu tun hat, das ist klar. Aber vor allem denkt man sich ja bei ESA immer, Wissenschaftler, und hier wird sozusagen diese ganze Technologie, die man eben benötigt, sich erarbeitet. Wohin muss man die denn transferieren?
Ich sage immer, unser Programm macht alles außer Raumfahrt. Wir haben im Raumbereich, im Raumfahrtbereich, beim Satellenbereich gewisse Probleme, Temperaturunterschiede. Es muss extrem leicht sein. Man sagt ja, der Professor Messerschmidt hat das mal ganz gut auf den Punkt gebracht. Wenn man einen Kilogramm einspart im Automotive-Bereich, also im Autobereich, ist es ungefähr 1.000 Euro einsparendes. Im Flugzeugbereich sind es 10.000 und 100.000 im Raketenbereich, also in einem Launcher. Und das ist typischerweise Gewicht. Es gibt viele Technologien, die getrieben werden von den Anforderungen des Weltraums. Und diese Technologie nehmen wir auf und transferieren das in Bereiche, wo diese Technologie nicht voreingesetzt worden. Also typischer Leichbau, was man heute im Auto hat, war vor einer Luftfahrt und war vor einer Raumfahrt. Das ist ein ganz plakatives Beispiel.
Also es geht hier nicht so sehr darum, die Technologie in die Raumfahrt zu bringen, sondern es geht vor allem darum und im Wesentlichen die Technologie, die im Rahmen der Raumfahrtentwicklung so entsteht, neu zu denken und neue Anwendungen zu überführen.
Es gibt, wenn man sieht, ist ein Unterschied zwischen, ich erfinde was Neues oder ich nehme bestehende Erfindungen und transferiere das unter dem Wort Innovation. Und dann nehme ich immer gerne meinen ehemaligen Arbeitgeber, wenn man das iPod, das noch einfacher sieht, der MP3-Player war im Markt vorher. Harddisk, also die Festplatte existierte. Die Software iTunes wurde teilweise zugekauft. Was Apple damals gemacht hat, ist eine geniale Systemintegration von bestehenden Komponenten. Und genauso hier setzt der Technologietransfer an. Also ich muss nicht immer was Neues erfinden, sondern ich kann bestehende Sachen in andere Bereiche transferieren. Und genau das macht der Technologietransfer in jedem Bereich, den man sich vorstellen kann.
Alles außer Raumfahrt, d.h. Raumfahrtingenieur bist du nicht?
Ich bin Wirtschaftsingenieur von Ausbildung. Also Spezialisten haben wir in der Industrie, in der deutschen und europäischen Raumfahrtindustrie genügend, auch bei der ESA. Und ich mache genau diesen Job, der eigentlich in der Studienbeschreibung drinsteht als Wirtschaftsingenieur. Ich verbinde die Wirtschaft oder verschiedene Technologiebereiche und hol mir die Essenz raus und bringe A und B zusammen.
Ich hab schon eingangs ein bisschen salopp dahingesagt zwischen den Zeilen, aber das scheint es dann auch ganz gut zu treffen, oder? Dann lebt man hier auch so ein bisschen zwischen den ganzen Gruppen, den Missionsplanern etc.
Ja, also das ist sehr gut getroffen. Ich sage mal, wir sind die Aliens in der Raumfahrt, weil wir natürlich unser Gesicht in die Nichtraumfahrtindustrie haben. Also wir reden mit einer Philips, einer BMW, mit anderen großen Firmen. Wir reden zwar natürlich auch mit den Raumfahrtfirmen, die für uns produzieren und entwickeln, aber wir müssen wirklich den Spagat mit den Welten machen. Ein ehemaliger Bundespräsident hat mal gesagt, ein Raumfahrtingenieur und ein Ingenieur im Automobilbereich sind in verschiedenen Orbits. Und unser Job ist, die zu synchronisieren und zusammenzubringen.
Ja, dann frage ich mich natürlich jetzt, Technologie Transfer Programm, wie ist das jetzt im ESA-Apparat aufgehängt? Wovon ist das jetzt ein Teil?
Es gibt mehrere Technologie-Programme innerhalb der ESA. Die sind programmspezifisch aufgebaut, wo man sagt, okay, hier ist dieses Wort Technologie, Readiness Level, also wie weit ist eine Technologie? Ist das eine Idee? Ist das ein Prototyp? Oder ist das dann schon wirklich im Flugstatus? Die sind aufgebaut nach verschiedenen Direktoraten, Programmdirektoraten und Bereichen, also zum Beispiel Navigation oder Launchers für die Raketen, die Areane-Raketen oder die Vega. Und unser Programm geht über alles. Also wir schauen uns wirklich unabhängig von dem Hersteller an, weil Raumfahrtechnologie gibt es ja eigentlich nicht, sondern wir haben ja Leichbau, wir haben Temperaturprobleme, wir haben Software, in dem wir extrem gut sind, Simulationen und das ist eigentlich der Schatz an Technologien und Know-how. Und oft ist es auch Wissen, was wir transferieren. Und da betätigen uns wir Goldgräber und sagen, okay, wir holen das heraus, tun das Abstöpseln von den bestehenden Einsatzgebieten und überlegen uns, was man damit anders machen kann.
Aber teilweise ist ja die Technologie in der Raumfahrt auch bewusst nicht unbedingt so die blutige Kante, das Allerneueste. Weil man ja auch sagt, das muss vor allem zuverlässig sein, das muss berechenbar sein, das muss sich am besten auch schon über mehrere Jahre bewährt haben. Man nimmt nicht den neuesten Prozessor aus der Prozessorschmiede, wo man auch nicht mal weiß, ob man nicht vielleicht noch mal einen Rechenfehler hat, sondern halt irgendwas Abgehangenes, wo man auch schon weiß, dass der ein paar Sonnenwinde übersteht. Wie ist das Verhältnis von Technologie, die wirklich jetzt so nur hier entwickelt wird und hier wirklich auch neu ist, versus einer Technologie, die eigentlich eher das Bestehende aus der sonstigen Wirtschaft, Technologie, Wirtschaft übernimmt?
Also wir haben zum Beispiel Transfere aus dem Bereich Hermes, das war ein Raumgleiter, den die Europäer damals bauen wollten, das ist 15 Jahre her. Da haben wir heute noch Transfers draus im Automobilbereich, weil ich nehme ganz gern die Automobilindustrie, in der Vergangenheit haben die 1 Kilowatt gerechnet, große Benzinmaschinen, war das kein Problem. Heute müssen sie vielleicht Elektromobilität in Watt rechnen, die Raumfahrt rechnet in Milliwatt. Also der ganze Trend, leichter, günstiger, effizienter, spielt da natürlich bei uns extrem hinein. Und wir haben so ein ähnliches Problem, wie auch unsere Kollegen im CERN, mit denen wir zusammenarbeiten. Wir sind in gewissen Bereichen schon voraus, aber auch die Sicherheit, dass es 100 Prozent funktioniert, ist für manche Industrie zwei extrem wichtig. Also ich nenne jetzt mal nur Eulengas-Industrie, mit denen wir zusammenarbeiten. Da darf kein Lack geben, wenn man Öl bohrt unter dem Meeresoberfläche. Deswegen sind die jetzt zum Beispiel nach dem Deep-Boat-Horizon-Problematik und dem Unfall auf uns zugekommen, weil unsere Technologie in der Robotik mag vielleicht einfach sein. Ist aber robust und funktioniert. Also im Design vorne, wenn in der Entwicklungsphase, überlegen wir uns schon, wie können wir Fehler denn von Anfang an vermeiden? Und einfacher muss nicht unbedingt schlechter sein.
Ja, stimmt. Das ist ein ganz anderes Risikomanagement. Wenn man so in der Industrie häufig den Fehler macht, dass man sagt, das muss sich rechnen und so weiter, und dann verzichtet man quasi auf diese Sicherheitsmargen, kann man sich das in der Raumfahrt eigentlich überhaupt nicht leisten, weil ein kleinster Fehler quasi das gesamte Projekt zunicht machen kann.
Und das ist nicht nur in der Raumfahrt, das haben wir natürlich auch überall, wo Menschen bezogen, Personenbeförderung, Flugbereich, Automobilbereich. Immer wenn es um Menschen geht, ist natürlich Sicherheit extrem wichtig. Und da gibt es schöne Beispiele, Strukturen wirklich live zu monitoren. Was macht eine Brücke? Da werden Sensorik eingesetzt, die ursprünglich in der Region eingesetzt wurde, um Strukturen zu messen. Glasfaser werden da als Sensorik eingesetzt, um Spannungen zu messen. Ist die Brücke wirklich noch stabil oder muss ich schon was machen? Das werden wir dann auch noch einsetzen in Windblades, um einfach zu sagen, Produkteile kleiner zu bauen, aber wirklich einen Gesundheitszustand permanent zu ermitteln.
Das heißt, Brücken sind jetzt genauso mit denselben Sensoren bestückt wie eine Ariane kurz vorm Start?
Ja, man muss sich das fast so vorstellen. Die Belastung, die wir heute haben im Schwerlastverkehr, haben wir in vielen Bereichen nicht in den 70er Jahren so gebaut worden. Also werden die saniert. Und in der Sanierung hält diese Sanierung so lang. Deswegen werden Sensorik in manchen Brücken schon mit eingebettet. Und die Sensorik erlaubt das zu messen. Stimmt die Spannung im Material? Ist die Brücke immer noch stabil? Und diese Sensorik ist die selbe Sensorik, die in der Leichtbrauchsstruktur eingebaut wurde, die im Raketenbereich fällen oder in anderen Leichtstrukturen.
Also so Druck- und Zug-Klensoren.
Finden sie heute auch zum Beispiel dem Öl- und Gasförderung. Die ganzen Leitungen, die verlegt werden, werden gleich mit Glasfasersensorik verlegt, um zu sagen, wie sind die Drücke. Um eigentlich zu sagen, es darf keinen Lack geben. Und das muss ich immer live monitorieren.
Ja, noch mal kurz die Frage noch mal nachgeschoben. Wie ist jetzt dieses Technologietransfer-Programm in der ESA organisatorisch aufgehängt?
Wir sind im Direktorat, was zuständig ist für Technologie. Wir sind ein Service-Direktorat. Wir allein, unsere Ingenieure oder unsere Ingenieure arbeiten für alle Programme, ob das jetzt bemannte Raumfahrt ist, ob das jetzt die Erdbeerobachtung ist oder die Navigation. Wir stellen die Expertise anderen Bereichen zur Verfügung. Und das Technologietransfer-Programm ist einer dieser Service-Einheiten. Wir schauen erst mal, was die ESA macht, aber 90 Prozent unseres Budgets geht an die Raumfahrtindustrie. Also die ESA baut ja nicht selber, sondern das macht die Europäische Raumfahrtindustrie. Und wir schauen auch, was machen unsere Zulieferer und unseren Partner. An was entwickeln die? An was arbeiten die? Wir reden mit denen und nehmen dieses Wissen und fragen auf der anderen Seite den Entwicklungsingenieur in der Automobilindustrie, weil sie nicht schlafen ist nachts. Und diese ganzen, die Offers, also die Offerte, die wir haben und das Bedürfnis in dem anderen Bereich bringen wir zusammen. Und das ist meistens auch interdisziplinär. Deswegen haben wir Bereiche aus der beidemandenen Raumfahrt, die bis in die Lebensmittelindustrie gehen.
Bisschen ketzerisch gefragt, warum macht das die Industrie nicht selbst?
Oft ist es so, das ist wie oft, wenn man eine Party hat und man kennt alle Leute, dann ist man ein bisschen langweilig. Man redet nur mit den Leuten, die man kennt. Die schönsten Partys sind diese, die Amerikaner sagen dazu, Mixed Pickles Party, wo ich Interessantes ist. Wie ich vorher schon erwähnt habe, die zwei Ingenieure reden nicht. Der kennt seine drei Kollegen in seinem Bereich, in seinem Luftfahrt- und Raumfahrtbereich, wüsste aber jetzt nicht, dass in der Lebensmittelindustrie eine ehemalige Problematstellung, der ein anderer Kollege arbeiten würde. Die treffen sich maximal im Zug oder auf einer Party, per Zufall, aber nicht aktiv. Die gehen auf eine andere Konferenz, auf ein Event, auf andere Messen. Der kommt gar nicht darauf. Man ist so fokussiert auf sein Spezialwissen, was ganz natürlich ist, weil wir sind Spezialisten in diesem Bereich. Und die ESA hat die besten Spezialisten, vielleicht noch abgesehen von unseren Kollegen in den nationalen Agenturen, dann kriegt man einen gewissen Tunnelblick automatisch, weil man einfach so spezialisiert ist. Das ist nichts Negatives. Unser Job ist es, so ein bisschen aufzubrechen.
Das heißt, die ESA betätigt sich sozusagen in der Wirtschaft auch noch als Dating Service.
So würde man sagen. Und dieser Service ist auch free of charge. Man muss rechnen, jeder europäische Bürger zahlt einen Kaffee für die Raumfahrt im Jahr, umgerechnet. Das ist so sein Einsatz. Und mein Job ist es natürlich zu sehen, dass man dann ein Cappuccino daraus macht, vielleicht oder einen verlängerten, wie die Österreicher sagen, dass das Investment, was der Steuerzahler gemacht hat, auch zurückfließt in andere Bereiche. Und da ist natürlich der Fokus auf unseren Mitgliedsstaaten. Das muss zurück nach Europa fließen.
Wie sieht das jetzt konkret aus? Also womit beschäftigt ihr euch? Das heißt, ihr seid im Wesentlichen dabei, erst mal alle Aktivitäten permanent zu beobachten, regelmäßig zu hinterfragen. Also erst mal muss ja dieses Wissen um die Technologie auch in irgendeiner Form gewonnen werden. Man muss ja erst mal irgendwie Ernte einfahren, bevor man was verteilen kann.
Richtig, das ist viel, viel, viel Handarbeit. Oder man muss seinen Acker bestellen und das tun wir. Dieses Programm existiert seit 21 Jahren. Wir schauen natürlich erst mal intern, was wir haben, was für Schutzrechte, also Patente oder Copyrights für Software generiert werden. Wie ich schon vorher erwähnt habe, 90 Prozent macht die Industrie. Deswegen haben wir ein Netzwerk von lokalen Brokern. Das sind Firmen, die auch sowieso schon in diesem Transferbereich arbeiten. Die werden von uns bezahlt und gehen wirklich zur Raumfahrtindustrie und sagen, an was arbeitet ihr gerade? Was sind das für Technologien? Und versuchen das auch ein bisschen zu abstrahieren, um das zu erfassen, für welche anderen Bereiche das gebraucht werden kann. Diese Informationen tragen wir in der Datenbank ein, die für uns ein Arbeitstool ist. Und gleichzeitig versuchen wir mit den Innovationsabteilungen, der Industrie Verbindungen aufzunehmen und auch denen ihre Bedürfnisse zu erfahren. Und diese beiden Informationen bringen wir zusammen. Und das ist wirklich Tagesarbeit. Das ist wirklich rausgehen ins Feld und die Sachen sehen, was gerade gebraucht wird. Es gibt so oft so ein paar Trends, wie jetzt gerade die Elektromobilität oder Leichbau oder grüne Energie, die uns ein bisschen unterstützt, wo wir einfach sehr gut sind. Wir müssen sehr effizient im Raumfahrtbereich arbeiten. Wir können keine riesen Solarpaneelen bauen. Wir können keine großen Batterien mitnehmen. Also Effizienz ist ein typisches Beispiel, wo Raumfahrt extrem gut ist. Und das spielt so ein bisschen uns in die Hände.
Wir haben jetzt mal gesagt, das ist sowohl die Industrie als auch eigene Aktivitäten, die beobachtet werden. Was wäre denn jetzt mal so ein Beispiel für eine entstandene Technologie im Rahmen eines ESA-Projektes? Und wie hat es eure Aufmerksamkeit erhalten? Ich versuche gerade so ein bisschen zu verstehen, wie man dann das so beobachtet, um dann wirklich zu entscheiden, hier ist jetzt auch wirklich was Relevantes.
Vielleicht sollte ich noch dazu sagen, oft reden wir auch mit mittelständischen Unternehmen. Die können sich jetzt keine große Entwicklungsabteilung für den Nicht-Raumfahrt leisten. Dem helfen wir einfach auch. Mit Eigennutz muss ich ganz offen sagen, weil wir natürlich dann eine Industrie entwickeln, die nicht nur von Raumfahrt abhängig ist, sondern auch im Nicht-Raumfahrt-Bereich. Und das macht einfach eine Unternehmung immer stärker, wenn man zwei Marktsegmente bedienen kann. Ich nehme mal ein ganz altes Beispiel, aber das ist schon ein klassisches Beispiel, was auch die Kollegen im DLR mit unterstützt haben. Oder parallel eigentlich. Es gab diesen Hermes-Gleiter, diesen berühmten Europa entwickelt hat und der nie geflogen ist. Wobei Projekte, die nicht fliegen, für uns gut sind, weil dann sind die Ingenieure sehr oft mit der Technologie was zu machen. Und hier haben wir das Schiedseschutzschild angeschaut von diesem Hermes-Gleiter, also beim Wiedereintritt. Das war eine komplette Fläche, also keine Kacheltechnik wie im Space Shuttle. Und diese Keramikverbindungen, Verbundverbindungen sind relativ interessant. Und die wurden transferiert an SKL Carbon vom DLR und von uns an Brembo. Das sind die Hersteller eigentlich. Brembo ist der Marktführer in Europa für Bremsscheiben. Die keramische Bremsscheibe, die 60% leichter ist und 300.000 Kilometer hält, bis jetzt im großen Luxussegment der Automobilbranche eingesetzt wird, also Porsche, Ferrari, Lamborghini. Aber da werden immer noch, so viel ich weiß, um die 10.000 Sätze verkauft. Aber oft ist es so. Mein erster Golf hat auch noch keine Bremsscheibe mehr hinten gehabt. Das fängt meistens im Luxussegment an und geht dann rüber in die normale Anwendung. Und das ist ein schöner Bereich, wo ein Transfer ist, der klein angefangen hat, weiter wächst und eigentlich das Potenzial noch vor sich hat.
Aber wie geht ihr denn so vor? Macht ihr dann so ein Audit von so einem Projekt, dass der irgendwie ja hierher ist, da ist ja sicherlich was zu holen, da schicken wir jetzt mal die Truppen los und schreiben uns alles auf, was so dabei ist und dann kommt das in die Datenbank?
Ja, wir schauen uns erstmal die Verträge an, die die ESA abschließt, schauen dann die finalen Reports an, was da für Technik entwickelt wurde, fragen die Firmen auch nochmal aktiv, aber nicht immer, wenn wir fragen, kriegen wir die Antwort, ja super Technologie, das kann man sofort umsetzen, sondern manchmal muss man denen auch ein bisschen auf die Sprünge helfen.
Weil da herrscht ja bestimmt auch so eine gewisse Betriebsblindheit, nicht wahr? Man denkt immer so, ja, das ist jetzt hier alles für die Raumfahrt, man hat nicht den Blick für das andere.
Also wir leiten die dann natürlich auch an. Wir selber und unser Program haben natürlich da einen Blick geschärft und versuchen das zu abstrahieren. Was sind die Eigenschaften dieses Materials? Was kann das Material? Oder dieser Sensor? Und man versucht dann, das ein bisschen aus einer Distanz zu sehen. Und da hilft das auch durchaus, wenn man kein Spezialist ist, weil man fragt dann auch Fragen, die sich der Spezialist nie fragen würde. Also Fragen ist da durchaus erlaubt. Also dieses abstrahieren, wir schauen die Verträge an, die finalen Report, die uns die Industrie liefert. Und versuchen, das auf eine andere Ebene zu bringen. Das ist eigentlich der Hauptansatz. Das machen wir mit den Verträgen, die wir haben. Und auf der anderen Seite gehen wir dann in die Projekte zu den Firmen und sagen, ok, an was arbeitet, zeigt uns das mal. Und dann kommt eigentlich der Forscher oder der Entwickler halt schon in Schwärmen. Und dann kann man den gezielgerichtet darauf hin führen, das etwas abtragsamer darzustellen. Und oft ist es ja so, ist auch wie beim Psychologen, man muss mal den Spiegel vor einen halten, dann merkt man sehr schnell, was für anderes Potenzial da ist.
Ich mein, jetzt ist es in wissenschaftlichen Institutionen herrscht natürlich immer so dieses allgemeine Karma des Teilens von Informationen im Industriebereich. Das ist ja nicht unbedingt immer so. Werden einem da die Türen auch immer so geöffnet? Oder können wir auch vorstellen, dass sich da so einige so ein bisschen zurückhalten und sagen, ach, jetzt kommt ja wieder die Spione von der ESA.
Das ist ja der Vorteil der ESA. ESA ist ja neutral. Wir haben damit kein Geld. Sondern wir haben ein Budget, was etwas über 4 Milliarden ist. Und davon geht fast 90 Prozent der Industrie. Wir versuchen halt da wirklich mehr draus zu machen. Ich sag mal, es ist wie recyceln.
Aber mehr draus machen, nicht im Sinne von Einnahmen generieren, sondern mehr draus machen für die gesamte Gesellschaft.
Ja, das ist aber auch Einnahmen für die Industrie. Also wir haben zum Beispiel in Österreich einen Hersteller, der macht eine Schutzfolie für die Wärmestrahlung im Raumfahrt. Das ist diese typische Goldfolie. Und die wird eingesetzt in einen MAT-Scanner, weil auch da habe ich cryogene Anwendungen. Und ich würde mir mal behaupten, dass dieser Medizinbereich wichtiger geworden ist, als der Raumfahrtbereich. Für wen? Für diesen Hersteller dieser Folie. Das ist gut für uns, weil die Massen-Skaliereffekte, das kommt der Raumfahrt zugute. Der Medizinbereich ist eine wertvolle Industrie. Wir haben Innovationen in beiden Bereichen geschaffen. Wir haben hier jemanden in Europa. Da ist Mehrwert für die Raumfahrt geschaffen, für den Hersteller. Die Medizintechnik musste das nicht selber entwickeln, Siemen zum Beispiel, sondern konnte auf den bestehenden Zuliefer zurückgreifen. In Europa musste nicht nach Außereipa gehen. Also das ist eigentlich ein Win-Win-Win-Deal. Man braucht manchmal so, die Bayern würden sagen, manchmal muss man Schnaps mehr zahlen, um was zu erreichen, oder den Reibungswiderstand überwinden. Genau das ist die Aufgabe meines Programms, den Reibungswiderstand zu überwinden, die Leute zusammenzubringen. Wir wollen daran nicht verdienen, da verdient meistens der Bereitsteller der Technologie was. Aber die Hauptwertschöpfungskette ist der, der diese Innovation, die bereits existiert, nutzen kann. Weil eine Eigenforschung wäre meistens viel, viel teurer.
Das heißt, das Ganze ist im Wesentlichen eine breit angelegte Wirtschaftsförderung mit dem Nebeneffekt, dass sowohl die Raumfahrt etwas davon hat, zum Beispiel von diesen Skalierungseffekten, dass einfach Dinge einfacher oder billiger zu produzieren sind, die in der Raumfahrt benötigt werden, als auch, dass man eben vor allem diesen Rücklauf, ich meine, das ist ja immer das Versprechen von Raumfahrt. Wir forschen, wir brechen in Dimensionen vor. Natürlich ist es toll, immer auf dem Mars rumzulaufen, aber eigentlich geht es ja darum, dass wir hier auf der Erde vorwärtskommen. Und an der Stelle ist das eine Auswirkung. Oder siehst du das anders?
Ja, sag mal mal, wir machen nicht Raumfahrt, um Technologietransfer zu machen. So schön das wäre, aber wir sind dann, man muss auch die Dimensionen sehen. Mein Office ist ungefähr mit 4,8 Millionen Euro dotiert, mit allem drum und dran. Das Budget der ESA ist über 4 Milliarden. Das spiegelt natürlich auch wieder in gewisser Größenordnung wieder. Nichtsdestotrotz hat das natürlich, ich kann es mir nicht leisten, etwas zu entwickeln und das nicht in andere Bereiche einzusetzen. Das hat was rein mit einer Ökonomie zu tun, hat natürlich auch was mit dem Bereich zu tun. Unsere Beispiele sind sehr plausibel, wenn wir einen Anzug haben für Feuerwehrmänner, wo eine spezielle Kühlung ist. Das sind Sachen, die sehr plastisch sind. Das hilft natürlich auch unseren Bürger zu zeigen, wir machen nicht nur Forschung im tiefen Weltraum, sondern hier hat das auch wirklich einen Impact auf der Erde. Und das ist was Gutes. Das ist genauso wie heute. Man recycelt Sachen, man schmeißt seine Zeitungen nicht mehr weg, sondern man sammelt die, weil das ein Rohstoff ist. Und genauso ist es mit Ideen. Das ist auch ein Rohstoff. Und den kann man mehr als einmal verwenden. Und genau das ist unser Job. Und das kostet man gar nicht so viel, aber diesen Mehrwert müssen wir anfangen zu finanzieren, um den zu schaffen. Und am Schluss, wenn der Transfer da ist, finde ich das auch alle ganz toll.
Ideenrecycling. Korrekt. Du sagst, seit 21 Jahren gibt es dieses Programm. Da kann man ja schon ein bisschen zurückblicken. Wie hat sich das so entwickelt? Worauf hat man sich am Anfang gestürzt? Und wie ist das heute?
Ich möchte vielleicht auch ein bisschen ketzerisch sein. Das ist wie ein Kind, am Anfang krabbelt man erst und dann fängt man an langsam zu laufen. Später rennt man, man verrennt sich auch vielleicht manchmal. Mit 21 wird man erwachsen. Wir sind erwachsen in dem Alter. Wir haben uns rausgezogen, zum Beispiel aus dem Research and Development Bereich, also selber was zu entwickeln. Weil die ESA weiß nicht, was der Markt braucht. Sondern der Markt weiß das sehr genau. Wir haben angefangen vor sechs, sieben Jahren mit der Inkubation. Also Neugründungen, Neudeutsche, startup Companies zu unterstützen. Weil die Raumverdienungsindustrie gut ist, in ein, zwei, drei Stücke herzustellen als Produkt, aber keine 50.000. Da haben wir Probleme mit. Und wir haben mehrere Bereiche gehabt. Ein schönes Beispiel ist auf der Internationalen Raumstation ist die Glovebox und eine Unternehmung hat da einen Mechanismus entwickelt, eine Methode, um dieses zu sterilisieren mit Ozon.
Was ist die Glovebox?
Die Glovebox ist eine große Box, muss man sich vorstellen. Da hat man so Gummihandschuhe. Man hat das bestimmt mal gesehen, um Experimente durchzuführen, damit die Raumumgebung nicht kontaminiert wird. Also giftige Stoffe oder Reizstoffe. Und diese Glovebox, also Handschuhbox übersetzt, ist diese Experimentierumgebung. Und die muss dann auch sterilisiert werden. Und da wird Ozon eingesetzt. Und diese Firma dachte ich, tolle Sache. Da kann man doch mehr draus machen. Und hat dann eine kleine Apparatur entwickelt, um Dental-Equipment von Zahnärzten zu sterilisieren. Und das war ungefähr so ein Fünftel kleiner als der Mitbewerb aus dem arkenadischen Ausland. Das Problem war, das ist in der Raumfahrtunternehmung geblieben. Und die Firma hat nicht gesagt, wir gründen eine neue Firma. Wir holen uns einen Partner aus der Medizintechnik, weil da haben wir ja eigentlich gar keine Ahnung. Und holen auch vielleicht unseren Investor rein. Und deswegen ist dieses Projekt gescheitert. Und so haben wir eigentlich die Kooperation angefangen. Hätten die damals gesagt, okay, wir machen eine Ausgründung.
Woran ist es denn gescheitert? Also woran ist das konkret gescheitert? Klingt ja jetzt erstmal nach einer ganz logischen Konsequenz. Wir machen da eine Kooperation.
Und das haben sie nicht gemacht. Sie haben es nicht vom Tagesgeschäft der Raumfahrt getrennt. Und ein guter Raumfahrt-Ingenieur ist ein Perfektionist. Weil das muss 100% funktionieren. Das kann nicht repariert werden. Ich kann es nicht wie ein Auto in eine Werkstatt fahren und reparieren lassen. Ich will Perfektionierung haben in meinem Produkt. Und im Medizinbereich ist das schon auch wichtig. Aber wenn ein Produkt defekt ist, kann ich durchaus sagen, okay, da gehe ich zum Kundendienst usw. Man muss manchmal, wenn man eine Idee hat, das wirklich trennen und ein neues aufziehen. Das ist wie jemand, man auch sagt, bei Kinder und Erziehung muss man mal die Kinder rausschicken, damit sie wieder zurückkommen.
Aber wenn so ursprüngliche Ideen und die tatsächliche wirtschaftliche Umsetzung getrennt sind, dann müssen ja Patente dort an der Stelle vermutlich eine große Rolle spielen.
Spielen eine Rolle. Die meisten Patente, die wir entwickeln, werden von unserer Raumfahrtindustrie entwickelt, die bleiben auch bei denen. ESA hat eigene Patente, das unterstützen wir gerade. Aber auch die Patente allein ist interessant, aber oft ist es auch das Know-how, was da rum angeheftet wird. Es gibt natürlich im Biotechnologie-Bereich mehr Patente als im Physical Science, also in dieser Hard-Materie, wo wir, sagen wir mal, Maschinenbau oder neue Materialien, es wird immer wichtiger. In der Vergangenheit haben wir da gar keinen Wert draufgelegt, sagen wir mal, 10, 15 Jahre zurück vor meiner Zeit. In den letzten drei Jahren haben wir extrem Fokus auf die Patente, weil das einfach wichtiger geworden ist. Und ich glaube, die Hörer haben das auch gehört hier, wie große Patentstreitigkeiten ausgeführt werden von großen Unternehmen. Patente sind einfach Schutzrechte, um Industrie und meine Produktion zu erschützen. Und das ist, in meiner Sicht, noch nicht ganz angekommen bei unserer Raumfahrtindustrie, aber in Zukunft wird das mehr und mehr wichtiger.
Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so das alleinige Mittel, was jetzt hier eine Rolle spielt im Technologietransfer?
Nein, es ist nicht. Weil oft ist das auch Know-how. Und da bin ich wieder bei anderen Produkten. Ein Patent allein hilft mir nicht, um glücklich zu werden. Meistens bei unseren Start-up-Firmen, die wir unterstützen, ist die Technik nicht das Problem. Meistens ist es der Businessplan. Meistens ist es die Ausrichtung des Unternehmens. Meistens ist es, dass Entwicklung unterschätzt wird. Die Patente sind oft nicht das Problem. Und auch die Technik ist nicht das Problem. Das mag im Marketing, das mag meistens im wirtschaftlichen Bereich liegen. Ingenieure haben den Ansatz, wie ich vorher gesagt habe, perfekt zu sein. Und manchmal muss man schauen, dass man Prototypen hat, der 80 Prozent funktioniert. Und dafür finde ich einen Käufer. Und es geht weiter. Ich habe nicht die Ressourcen um 100 Prozent perfekt werden. Es gibt ein gutes Schreibprogramm, eines Herstellers, das ich nicht nennen möchte, das auch nicht 100 Prozent fertig ist. Und fast jeder nutzt es von uns. Und die Leute akzeptieren, dass ein Computer ab und zu abstürzt. Das würde im Raumfahrtbereich nicht funktionieren.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber da will ich das noch mal reinfragen. Dieses Prinzip der Inkubation. Klingt ja jetzt erstmal ganz klar so. Natürlich, neue Ideen, neue Firmen, Wirtschaft kann man da auf diese Art und Weise immer am besten umkrempeln. Aber wenn jetzt auch das Know-how eine große Rolle spielt, dann würde das doch wohl auch bedeuten, dass dann von den Firmen, in denen dieses Know-how erzeugt wird, dann auch Mitarbeiter in diese Start-ups überwechseln. Schwächt das dann nicht wiederum die eigentliche Struktur?
Also ich sehe das eigentlich ganz positiv. Mein gutes Beispiel ist hier in Eindhoven der Philips Campus. Die meisten Firmen sind dort entstanden, weil es Projekte waren, wo Philips sagte, ok, das ist nicht unsere CORE-Technologie, die brauchen wir nicht, ok, dann die Mitarbeiter arbeiten dran, und die haben sich selbstständig gemacht. Am Anfang war das auch wirklich so, ich möchte nicht Abfall sagen, aber Recycle, wir setzen da jetzt keinen Fokus drauf, es kann durchaus in die andere Richtung gehen. Heute ist es so, das ist der Ideenpool in eine andere Richtung geworden für Philips, neue Ideen für Produkte zu kriegen. Das funktioniert immer in beiden Wegen. Deswegen sag ich mal, das ist die Debatte, ist das Glas halb voll, half bare. Wenn ich innovative Leute haben in meinem Team und möchte daran entwickeln und glaube daran, dann geht der sowieso. Dann halte ich ihn doch lieber in meiner Nähe und ich beteilige mich als Firma vielleicht sogar an dieser jungen Ausgründung und habe immer noch die Möglichkeiten, dieses Know-How wieder zurück zu transferieren, falls es für mich interessant wird. Wenn ich das Risiko nicht bereit bin einzugehen, die meisten Firmen, die wir heute haben, da sind auch nicht die Mitarbeiter von ESA dabei, wenn ich jetzt den Statutier nehme, sondern Leute, die kommen und das Wissen von ESA haben wollen. Unsere Ingenieure sind sehr lange hier. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass die Gründer gehen per Default in ihren Genom haben. Sie sind aber interessiert, Leuten zu helfen, die Technologie, die sie über 20 Jahre manchmal sogar entwickelt haben, weiterzuführen in den anderen Bereichen. Genau das bringen wir zusammen. Das ist mehr so Onkel-Neffe-Verhältnis. Und wir sind eigentlich sehr neutral. Wir unterstützen diese Start-up-Firmen mit ein bisschen Geld, um auf die Wege zu kommen. Meistens investieren die viel, viel mehr. Wir helfen denen mit Zugang zu unseren Laboratorien und Experten-Know-How. Und sie kriegen unser Marketing. Wir helfen denen bei Messeauftritten. Die kriegen das ESA-Branding. Und das ist für eine zwei-Person-Firma, die gerade angefangen hat, extrem wichtig. Wir sind so der nette Onkel, der fair ist. Wir erhalten keine Aktien. Wir wollen sie nicht über den Tisch ziehen, sondern wir wollen wirklich helfen. Wir sind der Gärtner, der am Anfang hilft, dass genug Sonne und genug Regen da ist und die richtige Erde. Und wir sind interessiert dann später, den Erfolg zu zeigen und dann den Bürgern sagen, Raumfahrt kann viel mehr. Das ist Know-how, was wir haben. Und junge Firmen sind vielleicht ein bisschen verrückt am Anfang, aber viele verrückte Firmen sind ja sehr groß geworden.
Aber ein gutes Start-up braucht natürlich auch ein Funding, insbesondere wenn es noch nicht so viele Leute, insbesondere in der ursprünglichen Firma, wo sie herkommen, wo sie dann abgestoßen werden, so nach dem Motto, naja, damit kann man ja eh nichts anfangen, aber ihr könnt gerne mal eine Firma gründen. Dann klingt das ja nicht unbedingt nach einer großen Investitionsbereitschaft. Wo kommt dann das Geld her für solche Ausgründungen?
Also wir haben zurzeit sechs Inkubationszentren. Nummer sieben sind wir gerade am Unterzeichnen in verschiedenen Standorten.
Inkubationszentren.
Inkubationszentrum, das ist, meistens ist es eine Partnerschaft zwischen Inkubationszentrum dort, wo die Start-up-Firmen unterstützt werden. Die kriegen so einen Package-Steal. Und wir haben immer lokale Partner. In Darmstadt haben wir das, mit der Stadt Darmstadt und der Landesregierung.
Das heißt da in Darmstadt ist ein Zentrum?
Ganz korrekt.
Wo sind die anderen?
In Oberpfaffenhofen haben wir eins, das ist bei München. Das machen wir zusammen mit dem Anwendungszentrum Oberpfaffenhofen. DLR ist ein Boot, das Bayerische Ministerium. Wir haben eine Außenstelle in Nürnberg, da machen wir das für das Fraunhofer-Institut, IIS. Die kümmert sich um Navigation. Das ist auch das Institut, wo Richtung MP3 entwickelt wurde. Wir machen dasselbe in Berchtesgaden. Das ist ein Zentrum in Bayern. Wir haben das hier in Estec, in Nordweg. Und auch da haben wir immer den lokalen Partner. Eine Firma, die das Zentrum betreibt, also Office, Stuhl, Telefon zur Verfügung stellt, Consulting, Coaching im Bereich, wie schreibt man einen Businessplan, wie patentiert man, wie melde ich eine Firma an, wie steuerrechtlich. Wir haben den Holländischen Staat hier drin. Zusammen mit dem Holländischen Staat haben wir ein Incentive, nennt sich das. Das ist eine Anschubfinanzierung von 50.000 Euro. Wir haben aber auch die lokale Bank, die Raubobank, das wäre die Reifeisenbank, wenn man es übersetzen würde, die einen kleinen Darlehen zur Verfügung stellt, aber auch ein Bankkonto und die nötigen Versicherungen. Wir haben die ESA als Technologiepartner. Die Firmen haben dann die Möglichkeit, mit unseren Ingenieuren, mit unseren Spezialisten zu reden oder Labore zu benutzen. Also es ist wirklich so ein Packagedeal. Und darüber hinaus sind wir in England, in Belgien. Wir haben mehr Anfragen, als wir eigentlich bewerkstelligen können von unserem Budget.
Aber es ist schon interessant, dass jetzt so viele Zentren in Deutschland sind, hat das einen besonderen Grund?
Man muss auch so sehen, der ESA-Anteil bei der Gesamtfinanzierung ist ungefähr bei Bayern und auch bei Baden-Württemberg. Aber bei Bayern ist es auswendig bei 26 Prozent. Der Rest wird lokal finanziert. Vielleicht sind wir der Brandbeschleuniger für Innovationen in manchen Bereichen.
Was heißt jetzt Ortslokal?
Man sagt, ein Inkubationszentrum hilft ja der lokalen Wirtschaft. Man muss das ganz klar sehen. In Bayern werden 20 Firmen pro Jahr neu gegründet. Das ist ungefähr das Target. Wenn es ein bisschen weniger sind, sind wir nicht böse, weil die Qualität ist wichtig.
Also aus dem Technologietransferprogramm heraus?
Ja, es muss ja nichts aus uns heraus sein, sondern Firmen, die Raumfahrtechnologie einsetzen. Wir haben das Problem, wir wollen die und die Raumfahrtechnologie einsetzen. Wir brauchen eure Hilfe.
Das sind 20 pro Jahr?
In Bayern zehn nochmal in Hessen, also 30 in Deutschland.
Die dann auch in irgendeiner Form ein Programm in Verbindung stehen?
Richtig.
Aber nicht alle finanziert werden?
Doch, alle von uns finanziert werden, zusammen mit den Partnern. Also jeder von denen kriegt ein Package, das ist unterschiedlich, mehr oder weniger. Kommt das auf die lokale Förderung an, aber idealerweise ist es um die 50.000. Noch mal ein Darlehen um einen ähnlichen Bereich. Man muss mal so 100.000 Euro rechnen, dass man eine Firma, sagen wir mal, anfängt zu gründen. Und meistens tun die Gründer über die Familie, Freunde oder sonstige Bekannte noch zusätzlich Geld einspeisen. Die meistens zahlen sich auch kein eigenes Gehalt in den ersten Jahren. Und das ist schon der erste Schritt. Und später helfen wir denen natürlich mit zusätzlichen Finanzierungen. Die ESA hat einen eigenen Fonds aufgebaut. Wir reden mit den Business Angels in den Regionen. Wir reden mit den Wagnis-Finanzierungen. Deswegen, wir als Gärtner können am Anfang übernehmen, aber dann später brauchen wir den großen Regenguss. Der muss dann jemand anders machen.
Aber um das mal ein bisschen zusammenzufassen, im Rahmen des Technologie-Transfer-Programms gibt es eigentlich viele Rollen, die gleichzeitig gespielt werden. Auf der einen Seite macht man so eine Art inhaltliches Scouting. Man zieht los, man beobachtet die Industrie, man beobachtet die Projekte, prüft entworfene Technologie und umgesetzte Technologie vor allem. Daraufhin, ob sie in irgendeiner Form eine Anwendung in der sonstigen Wirtschaft hat, wo es ein paar Hotspots gibt, aber auch das ist relativ breit gestreut. Und aus diesen Kontakten, die sich daraus ergeben, kann es dann auch so weit kommen, dass dann eben Gruppen angesprochen werden und sagen, entweder kommen sie von alleine, weiß ich nicht, oder werden vielleicht auch ermutigt. Man sagt, okay, vielleicht wäre das für euch ja ein Modell, das hier auch mal wirklich aktiv zu einem Punkt zu führen, dass man es auch über die Idee hinaus zu einer Realisierung bekommt. Und dann betätigt sich die ESA auch als konkreter Financier, nicht alleine, aber auch.
Also wir nehmen auch keine Anteile, sondern wir wollen da neutral bleiben. Das ist ganz wichtig. Und deswegen werden wir auch als adäquater Partner gesehen. Wir wollen jetzt nicht Prozente der Firma haben, sondern wir helfen in dem ersten Bereich, wollen aber neutral bleiben. Wichtig ist, wir entscheiden nicht, was die Leute gerade brauchen, sondern sagen wir, die Gründer, der Mittelstand oder die Unternehmen wissen sehr selber, in welchem Bereich. Und ich muss ein Tool haben oder einen Werkzeugkasten, der nicht nur einen Hammer hat, sondern auch eine Beißzange oder Schrauben. Und genauso sind wir eigentlich aufgebaut. Wenn jemand nur eine Lizenz braucht, kriegt er die bei uns genauso. Ich sag mal, schon vielleicht gemischt war ein Handel, ist vielleicht etwas falsch ausgedruckt, aber wenn man eine Lizenz kriegt, kriegt man die bei uns genauso. Wie eine Technologie als Mittelständer, der schon im Markt ist. Aber wir helfen auch Neugründungen, wo ich sage, ich habe hier zwei Studenten, die haben eine ganz klasse Idee, brauchen eine spezielle Software von der ESA, brauchen ein gewisses Know-how von der ESA, eine flache Antenne. Oder wir haben ein Beispiel gehabt, da geht es um Online-Racing, also das Live-Signal eines Rennens, eines Formel-1 oder anderes Rennen aufzunehmen und dann virtuell in eine Spielumgebung zu platzieren. Dass man live gegen den Rennfahrer rennen könnte oder fahren könnte. Die kamen zu uns mit einer Idee, die haben einen Patent gemacht, die haben von uns, glaube ich damals, waren es ein bisschen mehr Geld gekriegt, um die 80.000 Euro Förderung gekriegt. Sind finanziert worden von einem Wagnis-Finanzierungsfonds, sitzen heute in Aachen und haben, glaube ich, 15 Mitarbeiter und noch ein Research Center hier in Holland. Also das ist so ein gutes Beispiel, da sind wir der Schuhlöffel in die Wirtschaft hinein. Als fairer, adäquater und aufrichtiger Partner auch.
Aber ist das auch ein gutes Beispiel für den Rückfluss von Innovation wieder zurück in die Raumfahrt?
Das mag sein. Das Beispiel ist vielleicht jetzt weniger, aber ich nehme da das Beispiel unserer NASA-Kollegen. Innovation, Technologie, Transfer ist keine Einbahnstraße. Oft ist es so, dass wir im Bereich der Raumfahrt ein Problem haben, wo kein anderer hat. Und da setzt der DSA an, wir investieren in die Forschung, dieses Problem zu lösen, extrem leicht, oder bei drei Kelvin zu arbeiten, ein Instrument, oder sehr nah an der Sonne. Und wenn dieses Problem gelöst ist, oder die technische Herausforderung gelöst ist, und es geht dann als Transfer in die Wirtschaft, und wir holen es später wieder ab, wenn wir es wieder brauchen, verbessert, ist es wunderbar. Also Innovation, Spin-off, Spin-in kann durchaus als Kreislauf gesehen werden.
Ja, aber fällt dir gerade noch ein konkreteres Beispiel ein, wo der Swing hin in die Wirtschaft und wieder zurück ganz gut gepasst hat?
Ja, ich glaube, zwei Beispiele. Ich nehme mal die Schweiz. Die sind genau in diesem Prozess. Die entwickeln für die ESA Sensoren für Langzeitmaßmissionen. Und wir sind ja noch nicht bekanntlich auf dem Mars. Diese Sensoren nehmen Vitaldaten ab. Das ist eine Schweizer Forschungseinrichtung, CICM. Die bauen auch die Uhren für die Galileo-Satelliten.
Vitaldaten jetzt von den potenziellen Reisenden?
Richtig. Die werden heute schon eingesetzt, diese Sensoren auf der Concordia Antarctic Station, um getestet zu werden. Und die...
Sind die auch beim Mars 500 schon zum Einsatz gekommen?
Nee, ich glaube damals waren sie nicht dabei. Das war aber im Gespräch. Diese Sensoren sind relativ klein. Und die Forscher und der technische Officer, der ESA, also der begleitende Ingenieur, haben von Anfang an gesagt, ok, Mars, das ist so weit weg. Wir müssen von Anfang an schauen, dass wir einen Dual-User, also eine Doppelnutzung von Anfang an herkriegen. Also haben sie einen Prototyp gebaut mit diesen Sensoren. Der eine oder andere wird das kennen. Das ist ein Device, wenn man joggen geht, kann man sich das hier auf die Brust schnallen, um den Herzschlag zu hören. Und die Forscher haben gesagt, das ist eigentlich ganz schön umständlich. Es wäre doch viel schöner, wenn man Kopfhörer hat und im Kopfhörer, in diesen Earplugs, ist der Sensor schon integriert. Und genau das haben sie gebaut. Wurde, glaube ich, letztes Jahr oder vollletztes Jahr auf der ESPO vorgestellt. Das Device ist dann ein Apple-iPhone oder ein sonstiger MP3-Player oder ein Telefon. Und diese Vitaldaten werden davon aufgenommen. Also die Arbeit der Raumfahrt war dauernd, miniaturisieren, klein, robust zu machen. Und der ideale Ansatz ist jetzt immer zu finden, der das zur Marktreife weiter noch führt, in den Markt bringt und wenn wir in 20 Jahren zum Mars fliegen.
Da sind schon eine Menge Jocker damit rumgelaufen und haben gezeigt, dass das auch funktioniert.
Und wir holen uns diesen Sensor aus dem Regal. Das ist eigentlich Aufgabe. Die Raumfahrt, und so sieht sich auch die ESA in vielen Bereichen, wir müssen dort investieren, wo Technologie nicht vorhanden ist. Wenn sie vorhanden ist, ist unser Job getan. Und das ist dann der typische Spin-In wieder, der dann später kommt. Und wir suchen uns ein neues Problemfeld, wo man sagt, okay, da müssen wir noch besser werden. Wir müssen noch kleiner werden. Wir müssen noch leichter werden.
Aber das heißt ja auch, dass man nicht nur beobachten muss, was schon entwickelt wird, sondern muss auch beobachten, wo es noch Bedarf gibt, also wo noch nach Lösungen gesucht wird.
Wir reden natürlich auch, ich nehme an, du meinst ja, unsere Nichtraumverdindustrie, wo Bedarf ist.
Ja, überhaupt, ich meine, wenn jetzt so ein spezifisches Problem da ist in einer Mission, dann wird das ja erst mal im Rahmen des Projektes selber diskutiert. Und dann steht natürlich erst mal so auf dem Tisch, dass man dann so, ja, da müssen wir jetzt selber forschen. Wie erreicht euch das, dass das irgendwie so wieder...
Und das sind die ganzen Bereiche der Technologieprogramme, wo die ESA in Technologie investiert. Wir haben eine Mission, die haben einen Auftrag, ob das jetzt eine wissenschaftliche Mission ist, die haben einen Auftrag und dann sagt, okay, die haben die Problemstellungen und durch unsere Technologieprogramme wird dort geforscht. Und das sind die Verträge, in die wir wieder reinschauen. Da gibt es keinen gradlinigen Weg. Meiner Ansicht nach wird zu wenig in Dual Use oder Doppelnutzung. Man trennt immer noch gerne den Technologietransfer. Das ist wie, wenn man ein Produkt konzipiert, von Anfang an, dass es recycelt wird. Das ist sehr einfach zu recyceln. Auto ist ein gutes Beispiel. Das duale System ist vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein gutes oder schlechtes Beispiel ist. Wenn man am Ende eines Prozesses überlegt, was kann man damit machen, ist das immer schwieriger. Also es ist immer besser, zu sagen, was kann ich von Anfang an gleich damit machen. Das kostet wenig Ressourcen. Und die Konzeption hilft später, da ist ein Faktor 10 bestimmt möglich, mehr draus zu machen.
Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, meinst du, dass man bei künftigen Planungen mehr von so einem Dual-Use ausgehen sollte? Dass man in die gesamte Planung das von vornherein mit einbezieht? Aber das ist natürlich auch eine Belastung für die Wissenschaftler, oder? Oder ist das nur noch eine zusätzliche Herausforderung?
Das ist eine Belastung, eine finanzielle Belastung auch. Das mag vielleicht im 2-3%-Bereich liegen, ist aber später viel effektiver. Das ist genauso, wenn man sagt, man hat ein Haus und hat es von Anfang an günstig gebaut, Richtung Energie-Nutzung, ineffizient. Wenn man das von Anfang an macht, spart man auch was. Über den Zeitraum von 20 Jahren, man zitiert sich das meistens, oder 10 oder noch schneller. Wenn man später ein Gebäude hat und tut das Dämmen, dann ist das teuer und nie so effizient. Also der gute Ingenieur denkt am Anfang nach und dann geht er in die Produktion oder in die Planung. Wenn man von Anfang an einen Dual-Use-Ansatz, also die Doppelnutzung sieht, ist das immer effizienter. Am Anfang ist es immer mehr Arbeit.
Aber an der Stelle werdet ihr als Gruppe auch ein Ansprechpartner. Also angenommen, ich würde jetzt hier eine neue Mission leiten, keine Ahnung. Ich flieg, sagen wir noch nicht, irgendwie hier zum Uranus. Da muss jetzt erstmal noch mal sowieso 15 Jahre lang dran gebaut werden, weil das ist irgendwie verdammt weit weg, etc., und man fliegt an allen möglichen vorbei. Es ist finsterdunkel und finsterkalt. Jetzt brauche ich halt ein paar Schlüsseltechnologien, und dann könnte man quasi gleich andocken und sagen, hier, können wir nicht irgendwo mal die Lunte zünden, dass es da in 15 Jahren knallt, und dann haben wir diese Technologie auch, wenn wir sie auf den Launchpad stellen.
Richtig, also ich möchte es, vielleicht ist das richtige Wort, evangelisieren, das ist genau unsere Mission hier. Den Leuten zu erzählen, denkt man jetzt nicht nur in einer Einbahnstraße, denkt ein bisschen weiter, und wir versuchen da wirklich, den Räuzon zu erweitern.
Aber es liegt ja dem Wissenschaftler gemeinhin, nicht so in so einer wirtschaftlichen Richtung zu denken. Ist das so inkompatibel? Das ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders.
Also ich glaube, das ist, dann muss man mit denen anfangen, die offen dafür sind. Das ist immer so. Man wird nie 100 Prozent seiner Kollegen überzeugen. Aber auch das Problem hat die Wirtschaft auch, wenn ich zu großen Konzernen gehe und mit den Technologietransfer Abteilungen spreche, sagen die ja Salzgeber, passen sie mal auf. Seien sie nicht überrascht, dass wir mit Technologie Anfragen kommen, wo sie sagen, das passt doch gar nicht. Aber das ist der Kollege, der offen für neue Innovationen ist. Also ich kann nur Beispiel aus der Öl- und Gasindustrie nennen. Die Ingenieure sind wie unsere Ingenieure. Die mögen nicht ungetestete Applikationen oder ungetestete Produkte. Das liegt natürlich in der Natur des Menschen. Und da muss man dann, steht der Tropfen, erhöht den Stein, versuchen mit allen Mitteln. Man muss die ersten drei Leute kriegen in der Schlange und dann stellen sie sich auch noch mehr an.
Wie sieht denn dann eigentlich so dein Arbeitstag so aus? Also ich meine, wie divers ist das so aufgestellt? Wir haben es noch gar nicht erwähnt. Du bist ja jetzt Leiter des Programms. Wie viele Leute sind in diesem Programm eingebunden? Zehn Leute. Ist ja auch ein recht überschaubares Team. Wie teilt sich das so auf? Wie seid ihr da organisiert?
Also es kümmern sich ein paar Kollegen um den ganzen Bereich IPA, also Patente und Schutzrechte. Die Kollegen kümmern sich zum Beispiel auch um alle die Finanzierungssachen. Fonds, also ein Wagnis-Finanzierungsfonds. Das ist der einzigste der Welt, der in Raumfahrtechnologie investiert. Also das ist auch ganz eigenartig. Wir sind ja ganz stolz draus, dass wir da...
Der einzige Fonds, der in Raumfahrtechnik investiert.
Die nicht in Raumfahrt eingesetzt werden. Also es muss, also man muss sagen, es ist ein Fonds, der Firmen unterstützt, gemanagt durch Triangle Ventures. Das nennt sich Open Sky Technology Fonds. Und dieser Fonds unterstützt Firmen, die Raumfahrtechnologie im Nichtraumfahrtbereich einsetzen. Und der Vorteil ist, diese Sachen sind ja meistens getestet. Also ich meine, das ist ja, glaube ich, das beste Testbett, was es gibt, ist Raumfahrt. Was da funktioniert, funktioniert überall. Aber in der ganzen Welt gab es sowas nicht. Und deswegen haben wir gesagt, okay, wir müssen hier anfangen. Die Firmen, die wir unterstützen, haben ein Finanzierungsproblem. Und das Beste, da sind wir wieder bei den drei Leuten in der Schlange. Das Beste ist, wir generieren den ersten Fonds und überzeugen die Wagnis-Finanzierer und Geldgeber, dass das ein sehr gutes Investment ist. Das ist ein Teil unserer Aufgabe, diese Community zu betreuen. Also das, sagen wir mal, das ist ein ganz kleiner Teil meiner Aufgabe. Das Team zu steuern. Ich habe es mir nicht nehmen lassen und sitze auch in dem Auswahlverfahren eines Inkubationszentrums drin. Es ist wichtig, dass man so ein bisschen noch Gefühl für das Tagesgeschäft hat. Und dann sieht man auch die jungen Firmen. Also das ist ein Teil meiner Arbeit. Die ESA-Administration kommt da natürlich ganz klar dazu. Und alle, sagen wir mal, Stakehold, das ist, glaube ich, das neu deutsche Wort, oder Organisationen dort so hinzubringen, dass sie uns weiter unterstützen. Man muss mit den nationalen Agenturen reden, man muss mit der Industrie reden. Auch das versuche ich nicht nur, dass meine Kollegen das machen, sondern dass ich das auch ab und zu selber mache, um einfach nicht so die Straßenhaftung zu verlieren. Und dann sage ich natürlich, okay, bestimmt 20 Prozent der Arbeit ist Administration, die eine internationale Organisation automatisch mit sich bringt. Wir versuchen aber sehr viel draußen zu sein, weil der Kunde kommt ja nicht zu uns, sondern wir müssen zu dem Kunden kommen. Also letzte Woche war ich am Bodensee, da haben die drei Anrainer starten, über Raumfahrtechnologie gesprochen und auch wirklich aktiv vor Ort zu aktivieren. Wir sind sehr viel auf Messen, wir sind sehr viel auf Veranstaltungen, vor allem auf Nicht-Raumfahrtveranstaltungen. Also wirklich rumgehen mit der Ratsche und mit der Glocke, um Leute aufmerksam zu machen. Und das positive ESA-Image ist natürlich immer ein Türöffner, aber man muss danach noch den Sack zumachen und die Leute dann wirklich zu einem Projekt bringen. Das ist schon ein bisschen schwierig. Termin kriegt man schnell, aber die Leute dann dazu kriegen, wirklich in die Technologie hineinzuschauen und die dann wirklich noch anzuwenden. Das ist dann die Cure.
Wie ist da so die Reaktion? Sind die nicht erstmal ein bisschen überrascht?
Es ist ganz unterschiedlich. Deswegen versuchen wir auch, sehr plakativ zu sein. In dem Automobilbereich haben wir eine sehr schöne Veranstaltung gehabt, letzten September, einen Tag vor der Automobilausstellung in Frankfurt. Und da kamen 200 Leute, die sogar etwas gezahlt haben, um bei dieser Veranstaltung teilzunehmen.
Also der Veranstaltung, die dann von euch organisiert wurde und ausgerichtet?
Richtig, von einem unserer Brokern. Da ging es um Automobil, Automobilbusiness, also die Automobilbranche und Raumfahrt. Und da gibt es schon schöne Bereiche. Es gibt ja eine Firma, die...
Flying Cars.
Ja, so ungefähr. Endlich. Da wird der TÜV noch was dagegen haben. Aber ein gutes Beispiel ist die Schweizer Firma Max Motors. Die haben die Motoren für Spirit and Opportunity gebaut, die Mars Rover der amerikanischen Kollegen von NASA. Die haben dann später gesagt, naja, okay, wir haben nicht so viele Motoren verkauft, Elektromotoren. Es hat uns natürlich auch was gebracht vom Image her, vom Marketing. Aber was sie wirklich rausgezogen haben aus diesem Projekt ist, ein immenses Wissen, ihre elektrischen Motoren in einem harshen Environment, also in einem schwierigen Umweltbedingungen einzusetzen. Wenn man heute dann in die Elektromobilität gehen, mein Volkswagen soll natürlich auch in Sibirien, aber auch in Saudi-Arabien fahren. Das sind natürlich Temperaturbereiche, die typisch für die Raumfahrt sind, aber im Automobilbereich, also im Elektromobilitätsbereich, gar nicht so drüber nachgedacht wurden. Das ist so, das ist Know-how, was dort gewonnen wird, ist extrem wichtig. Und im Automobilbereich, ich hab noch ein anderes Beispiel, das wurde von uns Kleing unterstützt, da geht es um diese Hitzeschutzbleche. Um meinem Aufspuff habe ich Hitzeschutzbleche, die die Karosserie schützen. Die werden heute aus Aluminium geformt, die sind so 0,8 Millimeter dick und halten so bis zu 180 Grad. Und eine unserer Raumfahrtfirmen, eine ganz kleine Firma aus Deutschland, kann sowas formen. Die machen auch unsere Schutzschilde, Hitzeschutzschilde, auf Titanium. Und die sagen, wir können eigentlich diese Herstellungsmethodik anwenden, auch für Autos, und dann machen wir es nicht mehr aus Aluminium, wir machen es aus Stahlblech, bei 0,1 mm. Das heißt, es ist günstiger, es ist leichter, und es hält noch bis 400 Grad. Da geht es oft auch um Know-how und Produktionsknow-how. Und das Know-how muss natürlich in Europa bleiben. Wir haben bis jetzt fast keine Industrie gefunden, wo wir nicht irgendwie eine Technologie oder einen Ansatz haben. Von der Uhrenindustrie bis in die Schmuckindustrie, Medizin. Das darf ich leider nicht sagen, aber sonst kriege ich auf die Finger gehauen. Oder auch tolle Beispiele aus der Lebensmittelbranche. Der älteste Transfer, den wir haben, der wurde auch ausgezeichnet vor drei Jahren. Wir haben einen Hersteller, der baut Maschinen zum Abfüllen von Kartoffelchips. Und da rutschen die Kartoffelchips. Alle zwei Sekunden werden zwei Tüten abgepackt. Das ist die Geschwindigkeit. Und alles ist schneller geworden und schneller geworden, bis auf diese Verpackungsmaschine. Und der Hersteller hat dann mit Luftströmen gearbeitet, aber dann kam nur noch Brösel raus. Und der Kunde ist natürlich nicht bereit, für Brösel zu zahlen. Und wir haben einen Professor in Göttingen, der eigentlich die Corefee ist, für Berechnung für Wiedereintritt in Atmosphären. Titans Holgen hat er berechnet. Um die Sache mal kurz zu machen, haben wir eigentlich die ballistische Kennlinie eines Kartoffelchips berechnet. Und es war möglich, dass diese Maschine dann drei Tüten pro Sekunde abfüllt.
Das heißt, so wie man vorher ausrechnet, wie so eine Sonde auf einem fernen Planetenmond niedergeht in seiner Atmosphäre. Genauso wird dann so der Chip jetzt über dieser Tüte abgeworfen.
Ja, dieses Know-how wurde einfach da über Simulationen angesetzt. Und deswegen ist der Luftstorm richtig dosiert. Das ist die große Lektion, die wir dabei gelernt haben. Es gibt keinen verrückten Transfer. Und die zwei Menschen hätten sich nie im Leben sonst getroffen, wenn wir die nicht vorgestellt haben.
Kartoffelchips im Weltall. Wenn man jetzt so viel auf Messen ist und so viel mit Forschern zu tun hat, dann dürfte sich ja jetzt schon einiges abzeichnen, wohin die Reise geht. Also wenn man jetzt mal so schaut, was so derzeit köchelt, was sind denn so die Trends in diesem Technologiebereich? Was sind denn so jetzt die Sachen, die es hingeht? Ein paar Sachen sind hier vermutlich schon angeklungen, aber gibt es da noch irgendwelche unerwarteten Entwicklungen?
Also ich glaube, also effizient, energieeffizient, das ist großes Thema, das brauche ich gar nicht ansprechen, das weiß jeder. Ich glaube, dass viele Bereiche sich mehr überlappen werden. Ob jetzt das Nanotechnologiebereich ist, Optik, Nano-Optik. Also die Bereiche werden interdisziplinär verschwimmen. Einer der Bereiche, den wir sehen, der gerade anfängt wirklich ein Hype zu werden, das ist der ganze Bereich Location-Based Services. Also wir haben heute eine Generation, ich habe Zwillinge, meine Buben werden fünf. Die werden, Probleme haben, irgendwann eine Karte zu lesen. Das ist eine Generation, die immer online ist, die immer weiß, wo sie ist, und wahrscheinlich auch noch wissen, wo ihre Freunde sind. Und immer erreichbar. Und das alles wirklich in Echtzeit. Das ist, glaube ich, uns noch gar nicht bewusst geworden. Und der Ansatz oder die Erwartung an die Technologie wird noch extremer werden. Die ESA hat extrem tolle Daten, auch die nationalen Agenturen, über Beschaffenheit unserer Erde. Und ich glaube, dass das einer der großen, oder es ist schon angefangen, der Trend sein wird, diese Daten in Echtzeit überall darzustellen. Also heute zu sagen, ich schaue auf mein Handy oder mein mobiles Device oder mein iPad und sage, okay, ich gehe heute schwimmen. Gehe ich hier an die Nordsee oder gehe ich lieber in den See um die Ecke? Wie, ach ja, der See hat gerade eine Algendichte, die Wasserqualität ist schlecht, aber da gehe ich lieber nicht hin. Was hat die Wassertemperatur? Und mein Kind hat jetzt keinen Asthma, aber wenn er Asthma hätte, was macht der Erzogengehalt? Und wie hoch ist der Wind? Und alle diese Informationen habe ich heute. Bis zur Vegetation oder die Gewindgeschwindigkeit. Also das ist nicht nur für den privaten Gebrauch wichtig. Das gehört auch an Industrieanwendungen. Wir haben jetzt eine Firma, die optimiert Forstverwaltung aufgrund von Daten, die wir im Navigationsbereich aufgenommen haben. Aber da wäre es natürlich interessant zu wissen, ist der Boden gefroren oder ist der weich? Wenn er weich ist, kann ich nicht mit schweren Geräten hineinfahren, aber der ist gefroren, also kann ich mit schweren Geräten reinfahren und die Sachen abholen. Bis hin, dass ich sage, okay, ich möchte die Gewinngeschwindigkeiten der Vergangenheit wissen, auf eine gewisse Höhe, tu ich meine Windmühle hier aufrechne aufstellen oder vielleicht zehn Meter weiter. Das könnte vielleicht, wenn ich Glück habe, eine drei Prozent höhere Ausbeute machen. Und das auf 20, 30 Jahre ist das extrem viel Geld. Also diese ganzen Daten, die wir gesammelt haben, sind zwar zugänglich, aber noch nicht dort bei diesen tausenden Programmierern, die bei Android, Apple, Navtec oder Tela Atlas dabei sind. Also ich glaube, das wird einer der großen Bereiche sein, diese wirklich überzuführen in die Tagesanwendung.
Das ist aber doch weniger jetzt ein Technologietransfer, als mehr so ein Datennutzungsding, wie man so als Zuspieler agiert.
Da haben sie viele Algorithmen. Wenn ich mobile Daten habe, bin ich ganz schnell bei flachen Antennen, da bin ich bei Receivern, da bin ich bei Miniaturisierungen, da haben wir Technologien wie Piezo, wie man Energie gewinnen kann. Diese Firma, die wir damals geholfen haben mit dem Online-Racing, da geht es dann auch um Übertragung, Geschwindigkeitsübertragung. Ich bin jetzt nicht im GSM-Netzwerk, wo mein Telefon funktioniert. Was habe ich für Satelliten? Wir helfen dann auch schon in der Optimierung. Wenn ich einen Receiver, Sender oder Empfänger habe, ist ein Unterschied, ob der ein halbes Jahr hält oder ob der vielleicht fünf Jahre hält. Da bin ich im Softwarebereich, im Simulationsbereich. Ich würde es nicht so einfach machen.
Was ist mit der Umweltforschung bzw. dem weiteren Sinne des Umweltschutzes? Da spielt die Raumfahrt heute schon eine sehr große Rolle, weil natürlich gerade die globalen Daten, die bei der Erdbeobachtung gesammelt werden, da eigentlich die Basis sind für alles. Aber es entwickelt sich ja auch in zunehmendem Maße eine Industrie um diesen Bereich herum.
Das machen unsere Kollegen in Italien. Das ist die ganze Erdbeobachtung. Ich glaube, das funktioniert schon ganz gut. Das was Earthcare und die Erdbeobachtung ist. Ich glaube, wo noch Potenziale ist, ist in der Effizienz. Jetzt nicht von Daten, sondern von Technologien. Ich habe es ja vorher erwähnt. Bei uns, wir falschen wirklich um jedes Prozent in einem elektrischen Schaltkreis eines Satelliten. Zwischen Ladung und Entladung. Ein gutes Beispiel ist auch das RATV. Da hast du ja auch mal eine Sendung drüber gehabt.
Das Automated Transfer Vehicle, die Versorgungskapsel der ESA für die ISS.
Korrekt. Ursprünglich hätten da 800 kg Batterien an Bord genommen werden müssen. Und wir haben es durch Optimierung auf 200 kg geschafft. Das ist wirklich, und wenn man so sagt, das RATV hat eine eigene Stromversorgung, lädt, wenn die Sonne drauf scheint. Und dann wird das wie die Energie aus der Batterie gezogen.
Wer ist jetzt wieder in dem Zusammenhang? Also das Projekt hat es geschafft, das zu machen? Oder ist da auch der Technologietransfer zugekommen?
In dem Fall, das ist die Firma ERDS, Astrium, die das gemacht hat. Die hat ein gutes Simulationsprogramm dazu geschrieben. Und wenn man mal schaut, wie die Zukunft der Elektromedität von manchen Leuten dargestellt wird. Und man schaut das ATV an. Das ATV hat eine eigene Stromversorgung, lädt sich auf, wenn die Sonne drauf fällt, wenn es im Schattenseite ist, dann wird es aus der Batterie gespreist. Wenn es an die internationale Raumstation undockt, wird das Teil der gesamten Stromversorgung. Das ist so ähnlich, hört sich das an. Ich hab ein Auto, das wird nachts geladen, ich fahr rum und wenn ich daheim, das eine Steckdose ist, gehört das zu meinem elektrischen Grid, meines Stromnetzes. Das haben wir in der Raumfahrt schon. Wobei wir schauen, dass die Effektivität extrem gut ist. Und der Hersteller dieser Batterien, das ist die Firma Saft, hat gesagt, okay, unser Simulationsprogramm, also unsere Raumfahrtindustrie in dem Fall, der EADS, ist besser als ihr Ereignis. Das ist wirklich, da geht es drauf, wie mache ich Sachen effizienter. Und da, glaube ich, haben wir in der Raumfahrt noch extrem viele Bereiche, wo man sagen kann, wo kann ich noch ein paar Prozentpunkte herausschrauben. Ein gutes Beispiel ist da die Automobilbereich, nennen wir jetzt den Hersteller nicht. Das Hauptstromkabel ist nicht mehr aus Kupfer, sondern aus Aluminium. Das ist dicker, größer, aber leichter. Das kommt ursprünglich aus der Raumfahrt, dann war es in der Luftfahrt, jetzt geht es im Automobilbereich. Gewichtsparen.
Das bringt schon was, so ein Kabel auszutauschen.
Es gibt ein paar Hersteller, die wirklich schauen, an jedem Bereich ein paar Gramm zu sparen. Und über das gesamte Auto, wenn man das überall macht, bringt das was.
Ich war jetzt gerade so ein bisschen von diesem Forstbeispiel. Deswegen kam ich so ein bisschen auf die Umwelt, weil das ja auch sehr zusammenhängt, insbesondere im Agrarbereich. Und Effizienz und Umweltschutz hängen ja auch ein bisschen zusammen. Was weiß ich, wenn ich jetzt sage, hier muss gedüngt werden, hier soll gedüngt werden. Düngen ist an sich jetzt mal nicht so gut, weil das fließt ja wieder auch irgendwo hin und belastet das Grundwasser. Aber man will da trotzdem düngen, aber man muss ja auch nicht mehr düngen als nötig. Das ist auch so Bereiche, die eine Rolle spielen.
Die Landwirtschaft, unsere Kollegen von der GSA, die für Galileo zuständig sind in der Europäischen Kommission, haben gesagt, dass man die, die als erstes aufgeschrieben haben, als das Kontrollsignal oder Verbesserungssignal, Ignos, abgeschaltet wurde. Die Landwirtschaft setzt schon sehr stark drauf, aber auch da, gebe ich dir recht, sind bestimmt noch viele Potenziale. Da ist nicht nur das Bild, wie ist die Ausbeute, wie wird gedüngt, sondern wie wächst das auch. Und die Sensorik aufzunehmen, wie ist die Bodenfeuchtigkeit, wie ist die Vegetationsdichte. Und da bin ich dann nicht nur bei der Aufnahme der Satellitendaten selber, sondern da bin ich wirklich auch in Simulation, Softwarebilderkennung und das ist ein typisches Beispiel, wo man sagen kann, da ist die Software extrem wichtig. Das Bild alleine bringt noch nichts. Ja, ich glaube, dieser Markt hat extreme Potenziale. Und da werden wir noch einiges sehen. Es ist generell mit dem, das ist noch nicht in dem wirklichen Leben angekommen.
Dieses Team von zehn Leuten, sind das jetzt alles so Wirtschaftsingenieure oder ist das noch ein bisschen bunter zusammengesetzt? Also wer dockt an so einem besonderen Team an?
Also wir haben versucht so aufzustellen, dass wir eigentlich alle Bedürfnisse, wir haben Leute, die sind sehr lang bei der ESA, die kennen sich hier intern sehr gut aus. Wir haben wirklich Physiker, die technische Spezialisten sind, aber auch Leute mit einem rechtswissenschaftlichen Background, also mehr anwalztechnisch, da gerade wenn es um Patente geht. Marketing gehört dazu. Wir versuchen unsere Sachen sehr plakativ darzustellen, dass die Leute draußen das auch verstehen. Das ist immer eine gute Karotte, um ein neues Geschäft zu finden. Je bildlich man spricht, desto besser ist es. Also wir sind genauso bunt aufgestellt wie mit den Leuten, mit denen wir zu tun haben. Wir haben mit Wissenschaftlern zu tun, wir haben mit Ingenieuren zu tun, wir haben mit Wagnis-Finanzierern, wir haben mit Banken zu tun, wir haben mit öffentlichen Institutionen zu tun, wir haben mit jungen Firmengründern, wir haben mit großen Unternehmen und deren Forschungsabteilung. Und da muss man immer den richtigen Mix finden. Und das versuchen wir eigentlich auch darzustellen. Deswegen sagen wir, also ist unser Team sehr atypisch vielleicht für die ESA. Aber das muss es auch so sein, weil das ist unsere Aufgabe.
Es ist auch sehr atypisch für, ich meine, es ist ja so ein bisschen, man ist in der freien Wirtschaft, ohne an der freien Wirtschaft jetzt als solcher aktiv teilzunehmen, in gewisser Hinsicht. Und das ist ja dann wiederum eine Mixtur, die man dann so in einer Firma relativ selten findet. Also mir würde jetzt zumindest kein Beispiel einfallen, wo es ähnlich breit gestreut ist. Oder ist deutlich da jetzt zu viel rein?
Das ist schon, aber ich glaube, das ist auch der Spaß, den das ganze Team dabei hat. Wir sind so ein bisschen wirklich in der Reibungszone zwischen Wirtschaft und ESA. Und auch die Geschwindigkeiten sind total anders. Deswegen sind wir auch etwas ausgehackert vom Hauptgebäude. Aber das macht ja eigentlich den Spaß. Auf der einen Seite hat man die Zuverlässigkeit und durchaus die Behäbigkeit einer Raumfahrt-Agentur, die auch wichtig ist, weil das sind Projekte, die nicht leichtfertig entscheiden werden können. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir durchaus das quartalgetriebene Denken der Wirtschaft. Man muss schauen, dass man nicht zerrissen wird, aber das ist auch wirklich die Herausforderung und der Spaß, die wir dabei haben. Ich glaube, alle meine Kollegen teilen diese Emotionen und die Begeisterung für das, was wir machen. Da hören wir nie, dass es negativ ist. Wir haben eigentlich immer offene Türen. Und das macht eigentlich der Spaß aus. Und diese Vielfältigkeit, mit Leuten zu reden. Das bringt einen ja auch selber weiter.
Wie ist dann so das Außenverhältnis? Ich meine, abgesehen davon, dass man jetzt selber immer schaut, gibt es auch noch andere Methoden, an neue Ideen heranzukommen? Irgendwann bewegt man sich ja dann auch auf dem ausgetretenen Pfad, auch wenn man ihn erst mal selber ausgetreten hat?
Das ist korrekt. Also Innovation muss ja immer offen sein und vielleicht muss man auch alle 10 Jahre, hat mir mal ein Forscher gesagt, muss man seinen Bereich wechseln. Also habe ich noch ein paar Jahre Zeit, um auf neue Ideen zu kommen. Wir unterstützen einen ganz tollen Ideenwettbewerb, den nennt sich European Satellite Navigation Competition. Das ist ursprünglich, hat er in Bayern nur angefangen, in einem unserer Inkubationszentren. Heute ist das in 21 Nationen. Man hat über 400 Ideen, was man Verrücktes oder auch Nicht-Verrücktes oder Schönes mit Navigation machen kann. Mein Spitzname ist immer der Galileo Master, obwohl das mit Galileo gar nicht so viel zu tun hat. Weil man kann auch andere Navigationssignale einsetzen wie GPS. Und Galileo Master hört sich immer wie so ein bisschen Golfturnier an. Und das ist es ja nicht. Und diese 400 Ideen kommen aus den, letztes Jahr kam das aus 49 Ländern. Und das sind so Ideen, die wir auch aufnehmen und in die Gründungsförderung stecken. Was kann man Verrücktes machen mit Navigationen? Also dieses Beispiel des Rennens, was ich vorher genannt habe, haben wir dort gefunden. Das ist über diesen Wettbewerb gefunden. Und seit zwei Jahren haben sie den ähnlichen Wettbewerb parallel laufen für App-Eriptosdaten. Das ist der GMS Master. Um auch dort zu schauen, was kann man denn mehr machen? Und dort kriegen wir eigentlich die verrückten, ich würde nicht sagen verrückt, aber neuen Ideen rein, was man denn mit diesen Daten alles machen kann. Und ich bin ein bisschen eigennützig. Das ist natürlich der Dealflow, würde man sagen. Das sind die Ideen, die bei uns dann in die Gründungsplanung kommen. Die besten idealerweise.
Immer die besten Ideen. Haben wir noch etwas ganz Wichtiges vergessen?
Nein, also ich glaube, wenn man, wenn der Hörer sich nur merkt, es gibt keinen verrückten Transfer, uns kann man immer kontaktieren. Also wir haben zwar auch Bürozeiten, aber sonst eine E-Mail schreiben. Über Raumfahrt denkt man oft nur nach im Bereich der Raumfahrt und nicht im Tagesgeschäft. Und das ist eigentlich schade. Und das ist genau unser Job, das zu ändern. Und vielleicht für die Kollegen in der Industrie, die da interessiert sind, wir haben immer eine offene Tür. Und für die Finanzierer, das wäre natürlich schön, weil wir ein bisschen mehr Geld für verrückte Ideen haben. Aber das ist glaube ich ganz normal, das haben alle unsere Kollegen gesagt.
Ja, dann sage ich mal vielen Dank, Frank Salzgeber. Das war es hier mit der 35. Ausgabe. Und ich kann mich nur wieder bedanken fürs Zuhören. Hier geht es bald wieder weiter. Sagt Tschüss und bis bald.